Spider-Man Kills the Marvel Universe and
it's amazing you guys are gonna love
this story I know you guys love it when
horrible things happen to the
superheroes and like everybody dies this
story initially opens up focusing on The
Punisher Frank Castle now bear with me
here Spider-Man becomes a huge part of
this and in fact he's kind of the
Catalyst behind basically the death of
everybody so what is up going on is
Frank Castle is actually tracking down
Deadpool now of course Deadpool as he's
presented here when the story was
written at the time is very reminiscent
of that version of Deadpool over the top
silly he won't shut the heck up and what
Freddy Castle says is he says this is
the 33rd time I've hunted Deadpool the
33rd time I've killed him I've buried
him burned him dropped him in the Hudson
River weighed him down with rocks even
fed him to the lions in the zoo this
time I'm thinking pieces right cut them
into pieces that might work and that's
exactly what he does and then he puts
him in different parts all over the city
and so following this he gives us this
bit of an exposition on what happened
now here's the kicker Frank Castle is
initially going to tell us what happened
from his perspective then we're gonna
get Spider-Man's side of things and
that's when stuff gets really really
cool so he says this is the world now
right this is all there is as far as I
know it didn't start with Daredevil or
Deadpool they were caught up in a wave
that swept the whole world it didn't
start small life is not that subtle and
he says it started with a kind of big
sprawling superhero super villain fight
that New Yorkers see all the time the
kind that makes people think it's just
another day in the Big Apple only it
wasn't and so what ends up happening
here is that in the midst of what's
basically a sporting event Spider-Man
shows up fighting Rhino the problem is
once he overtakes Rhino and attacks this
guy and basically subdues him he starts
screaming about how like the meat is his
right and just starts like eating Rhino
like literally consuming Rhino on the
spot no this is not Marvel zombies and
so the Fantastic Four ultimately stepped
in and they subdued Spider-Man and so
the initial indication here is that
Spider-Man having his faculties
basically being able to think reasonably
so he is while Sanders a measurement his
normal self with the kind of reduction
in his intelligence of course Reed
Richards being the smartest person in
the Marvel Universe arguably people
start asking him questions and what he
says is that Spider-Man's not any kind
of a Mindless killer right he can think
but his higher reasoning functions have
basically been disabled he's been
reduced to a more primitive State kind
of a cannibalistic predator and he's
effectively just become simplified now
Spider-Man basically being held by Reed
Richards allows Reed to examine his
blood the problem with this is that
everybody believed that Spider-Man's
actions were a one-off and then Frank
Dukes The Blob walks into a diner and
eats everyone there and then following
that things start to go south right
Frank Castle says the next day a School
Bus full of kids went on a killing spree
in a shopping mall by the end of the
week the staff at a Philadelphia donut
shop formed a tribe and declared war on
the coffee place down the road the women
of the view went after the audience with
knives Daredevil killed and ate a couple
of nuns stringing their finger bones on
a necklace that he made from a rosary by
the time people knew there was a problem
there was no time left to stop it the
news feeds kept going on for about 10
days by the end of it hysterical stuff
religious stuff and then nothing and
then he says the internet went dark
after about a month by then most of the
power companies were folding people
panicked but there was nowhere to go the
plague was basically everywhere and it
wasn't at the same time people whenever
it wasn't in a location people brought
it there and so he says at first we
tried to capture and control then we had
to start killing people later it was all
we could do to stay alive as the
infections spread and every day was a
bad day every choice was a hard Choice
he had to kill Captain America Susan
storm took out Franklin and Valeria
which is really kind of Marvel's way of
nipping Franklin in the bud right I mean
he's a kid that has the ability to warp
reality one of the things that Frank
Castle Muses about is he doesn't know if
Susan storm did it because they turned
or if she did it as like a mercy killing
right to basically ensure that they
would never have to go through any of
that stuff following this he says the
thing formed a tribe in the Shell of the
Baxter building killed a lot of the
spandex crowd and then ate them skin and
bone and he says it took him nearly a
year to figure out how to take this guy
out and he says for months I heard about
pockets of resistance rumors of immunity
maybe it was true but it didn't really
matter sure some people didn't seem to
turn Savage but the ones that did ended
up killing them so none of it made a
difference right Thor was one of the
last to fall and he ended up killing
Hercules and ares and then literally
donned his hammer and took off so while
we're not given a definitive answer as
to where it was that he went to we can
largely assume he ended up going to
Asgard and likely turned everybody in
Asgard and everybody out there died but
for Frank Castle himself what he does
day in and day out is he hunts for a guy
named Zero basically patient zero now
you can tell by just looking at the
clues on the pages and so on and so
forth it's obviously Spider-Man but
what's going on here is that Spider-Man
is basically leaving clues for Frank
Castle for example he leaves the body of
a guy who was not infected and had
basically been killed and so what this
does is it tells Frank Castle there's
survivors here so if there's one
Survivor here there's more that's what
Spider-Man's telling him so it's kind of
you know Follow Me Right sort of leading
him into the darkness and so Frank
Hassell goes as far as the sort of muse
how all this happened in the first place
and what he says is that in his time
when he was doing Frank Castle Punisher
stuff right just acting and never really
thinking that word had reached his ears
of what basically seemed to be an arms
deal that was going down and that all he
really heard was like small and portable
so he assumed it was a suitcase
specifically because it was like some
Russian underground criminal bosses who
were basically meeting for this exchange
Frank Castle basically being an idiot
shows up and shoots the place up guns
everybody down come to find out what was
actually in this briefcase was a
substance called Survivor 118 and what
this was designed to do was basically
allow Humanity to achieve some measure
of post-apocalyptic life in the
aftermath of like a nuclear fallout so
in the face of humanity facing some sort
of a pandemic or some kind of nuclear
fall out in the aftermath of nuclear war
this substance was devised to basically
rework the structure of humanity when
Frank Castle shot all these guys up he
was blasted with a huge dose of it and
that seemed to basically make him immune
to the initial plague but in turn the
liquid itself seeped into the water and
the sewer systems which in turn
basically infected all the crops you had
scientists and people who were arguing
and bickering but the average person was
none the wiser so in this seventh month
time period between when Frank Castle
shot these guys up and when the
substance entered into the water system
all the way up to when Spider-Man
attacked Rhino people had no clue what
was happening they were just traveling
around the world taking this virus along
with them so in effect this was covid
before covid and so what ended up
happening is that by the time people
started to realize something was wrong
it was a great big huge blow up right it
was Spider-Man attacking Rhino and
eating him and so it's kind of nuts
because Frank Castle kind of blames
himself for the fall of everything right
he kind of believes he's the reason why
everybody has effectively died but in
the end he's still trying trying to find
like Spider-Man he's still hunting for
patient zero the guy who started this
and so in his travels as he kind of
continues to make his way through here
he ends up coming across the Incredible
Hulk now the Incredible Hulk by this
point in time isn't even really feral
and in fact I would argue this
environment is really the most conducive
to The Incredible Hulk where he's
effectively being left alone because no
one out there is stupid enough to attack
him right it's the Incredible Hulk and
because the Incredible Hulk is basically
hungry he immediately goes after Frank
Castle now the funny thing about this
and I'm not entirely sure I agree with
how this was done that what had happened
is that somewhere along the line the
Incredible Hulk had basically ripped
Wolverine to pieces in that giant battle
out there in Brooklyn and in essence
ended up consuming him now what he'd
also done is broken his arm off which
seems to be impossible given the nature
of Wolverine's adamantium bones although
the adamantium doesn't actually solidify
across the entire arm it's the joints
and things so I guess you could pull it
apart the part that I'm not so sure
about is Frank Castle ends up taking one
of the hands of Wolverine with his claws
extracted places it under a tank applies
the right kind of Leverage and snaps off
one of the claws and then in turn he
basically attaches it as an arrow and
shoots it through the eye of the
Incredible Hulk now I have a hard time
believing Frank Castle would somehow be
able to break off one of Wolverine's
adamantium bones but it's a comic book
who cares go with it so in the midst of
all this while he's basically escaping
from the Hulk because there seemingly is
no way to kill him he starts hearing a
cry for help now when he gets there this
is when things get crazy because as soon
as he arrives on the scene he ends up
basically seeing this priest right this
priest that's down there with this kid
this basically calling for Aid now this
is kind of their Hideout they've been
here for quite some time but they also
need help to effectively escape the
problem is that in the middle of all
this Venom shows up and Venom literally
starts attacking him now the funny thing
about this is that the way that he's
depicted he looks like one part Venom
and one part anti-venom there's not
really a definitive way to tell he just
kind of doesn't really give himself a
particular name just calls himself
venomous but the thing about this is
that Frank Castle is able to basically
take this guy out using a combination of
arms and Armament fire different things
along those lines the Symbiotes are
relatively easy to defeat at least they
were back then but where Frank Castle is
able to basically get this priest to a
measure of safety by freeing him from
the pit in turn you end up finding out
it was a ruse it was basically a trap
these guys were LED here right they were
basically forced here by Venom but when
Venom was destroyed the second guy
showed up which is basically Deadpool
who has essentially returned now it
doesn't immediately happen right off the
bat instead Frank Castle ends up leading
the priest and the kid back to his base
of operations and what's so interesting
here is that the priests despite
everything that's going on while he is a
little bit cynical due to some of the
decisions that he's had to make what he
also has I guess maybe by virtue of his
own religion is still a belief in the
sanctity of life and so in telling his
part of the story what he says is that
before everything popped off he
basically ran a soup kitchen but
somewhere along the line an infected
person showed up everybody else became
infected and it drew even more infected
and so basically the whole place turned
into a slaughterhouse now he tried to
find people and help them where he could
when he could and he said even at one
point he had hundreds of people that
were being kept safe right they were
being protected by all these different
cannibals that he had helped to
basically rescue and during this time he
had to do things like kill people the
priest approaches Frank Castle from this
perspective that he's quote unquote
doing the Lord's work which is to say
getting rid of all the infected to make
the earth a better place for the
uninfected the reality is it's anything
but the priest does not really
understand what goes on with Frank
Castle and his mindset and in fact when
he gets to Frank Castle's headquarters
you end up finding all the people that
Frank Castle had killed right all their
heads are on spikes Magneto name or the
Submariner and all that kind of stuff
even Blackboard which isn't really
surprising because Black Bolt sucks but
the thing about this is that the the
priests and Punisher have this kind of
conversation where it's one of those
things where it's like surely you have
to understand that indiscriminately
taking these guys out that it can't be
done from a place of malice or anger
though the response of Frank Castle is
no for me the world became a lot simpler
right every everything that was
important to me that mattered to me had
basically died right him of course
referring to his family which is kind of
the thing about Frank Castle right his
family was killed it all went
topsy-turvy for him whenever he looked
at the world as it existed before
everything went nuts you had all these
different Shades of Gray right you had
like people who kill somebody but then
it turns out to be manslaughter a person
robbed somebody but they do it out of a
place of desperation which they wouldn't
have normally done it then you have
criminals that just do criminal things
but in this world that he's in there's
the infected and the uninfected done and
that's it he kills the infected and it's
exceedingly simple it's a life that he
loves it's a life that he relishes in
right it's a very simple way to live but
the problem is that in the middle of
this whole conversation Deadpool
re-emerges and of course we're not given
a definitive explanation why initially
but we basically end up finding out
Spider-Man's forces are the ones that
freedom they dug him up and then
basically put him back together so his
healing Factor would take care of the
rest but when he arrives here he's
basically waving a white flag right he's
like no no don't attack me I have a
message right my boss The Big Cheese
zero the guy you're hunting for 4 he has
more survivors he wants to meet he wants
to talk right he wants to have a powwow
right like a parlay and where Frank
Castle initially rejects it and even
asks the question why would I go there
and talk to your cannibalistic boss I
kill you guys the response of Deadpool
is no you don't understand he's already
here and Spider-Man has effectively
arrived on the scene and snatched up the
kid and the Padre now this is when we
get into Spider-Man's perspective and we
find out how far gone Spider-Man is and
how his actions basically led to the
death of everybody not only that there's
somebody worse than Spider-Man out there
what he says here is that when the whole
plague basically broke out that Peter
and his forces broke into a tribal
mentality and so did virtually everybody
else what you had were effectively the
rise of like Warlords and Petty
strongmen and they started emerging and
essentially seizing control now because
you had superheroes out there and even
super villains because there really is
no differentiation anymore but because
you had powered people some of whom were
weaker than others then much like a
post-apocalyptic landscape in this day
and age the weak flocked to the strong
for some measure of protection and
that's exactly what happened here right
that you had Spider-Man due to the fact
that he has a Spider Sense which allows
him to overcome virtually any foe or the
very least survive any attack outside of
facing off against reality warpers or
people with insane levels of magic or
something along those lines but because
of his really his capabilities he was
able to outmatch and outclass a majority
of people out there so just by
Spider-Man on his own he cut a swath
through pretty much the entirety of what
remained of those people who had powers
and were infected not only that we we
get one of the most haunting aspects of
this and I'm curious to see how you guys
feel because anybody who's read this
story is like oh my God I know it's
coming yes you know it's coming when
there's this giant battle that that went
on right Peter Parker and his guys what
he said is that there's seemingly
somebody behind the scenes who is
pulling the strings that was pitting all
the different tribes and those survivors
against each other driving them in the
conflict to basically thin the herd
right to to kind of clear the landscape
for them to seize total control but what
had happened here is you did have kind
of a handful of humans and superhumans
who had survived and had never become
infected Iron Man Captain America so on
now Captain America eventually did
become infected but out of this one in
time he was not but the problem here and
even what Frank Castle says is he says
the last wave of uninfected Heroes
stepped up to help Iron Man Captain
America Wolverine a few others these
would have been legendary battles but no
one's writing history books anymore
those that didn't fall in the battle
fell to the bug Iron Man thought he was
safe in his climate-controlled suit but
why would he get a free pass locked in a
10 prison Stark screamed for five whole
days literally what happened here is
that when everything started shutting
down right when they when when Frank
house refers to as the bug all we can
really indicate here or really infer is
that it's just kind of either a
technological glitch or power just
shutting down to everything but by
whatever Manner and whatever means Tony
Stark was locked in his own Iron Man
suit he was stuck his suit became a tomb
and he died in it just screaming for
help and nobody could get him out it's a
fate worse than death it's pretty bad
but what happens here is that basically
Spider-Man reveals that the person who's
kind of been controlling things behind
the scenes is What's called the king of
death but the thing about this is that
he's not just some arbitrary guy who
does things that he is incredibly
intelligent and Incredibly cunning and
Incredibly ruthless he is Hardcore and
so what ends up happening is a deal is
struck between the two that what
Spider-Man says is if you travel to the
king of death and you get my mate bring
my mate back to me then we will have a
cease and desist right we will not
attack you We Take Manhattan you can
have the rest of the world without the
king of death all those forces out there
will fall into a state of disarray
you'll be able to continue your campaign
of killing people they'll be scattered
leaderless and divided so they'll be
easy to pick off because they won't have
any kind of a unified front you will
effectively win right all I want is for
you to get my mate and I will give you
the survivors and so ultimately Frank
Castle says deal and so what he ends up
doing is he goes out there into just the
kind of wilderness if you want to call
that the urban jungle but he's also
accompanied by Deadpool and a couple
other people who were sent by Spider-Man
to assist him in his efforts once they
get to the prison of the king of death
Frank Castle essentially Snipes a few of
these guys who are out here seeing all
these survivors and then realizes it's a
trap that these survivors that were put
out there they were put out there as a
distraction basically to lead Frank
Castle into just kind of jumping into
doing things first and not thinking
because that's Frank Castle's Mo right
he sees he shoots he asks questions
later and so by taking advantage of that
it allows these guys to essentially
attack him and so in that moment they're
able to subdue Frank Castle and take out
basically the forces of Spider-Man
albeit minus Deadpool right that guy of
course continues to survive Frank Castle
tries to throw some grenades but then he
ends up finding the mate of uh of of
Spider-Man who of course is Mary Jane
Watson not only that while these initial
I guess this first wave of infected were
destroyed the second wave steps in they
overpower Frank Castle but this time
it's also the king of death who's
revealed to be the Kingpin kind of a
perfect antithesis to Spider-Man right
of course Kingpin is incredibly
intelligent he's incredibly ruthless
he's cunning he's a great villain
probably one of the greatest villains
that Marvel Comics has ever had now of
course because the king of death because
Kingpin wants to expand his fear of
influence but Spider-Man and his forces
are the thing that stand in the way
Frank Castle is able to kind of help get
some of the survivors out of there to
basically get them away as fast as they
can and then in turn you basically have
him being subdued yet again and then
taken prisoner and so once he's being
held up by the king of death the first
question he asks is where Spider-Man and
his forces right where's zero as this
guy is known give me his location and I
will I will wait a little while but I
mean I'm still gonna eat you right I'll
just I won't make it as painful as it
could be now of course Frank Castle
refuses to Spill the Beans because his
loyalty is to the survivors that
Spider-Man still has it's very
altruistic in that way right all those
innocent people out there are counting
on Frank because Frank knows that if he
dies and if Mary Jane Watson dies all
those people all those survivors they're
just going to be food they're going to
be eaten and like that's really all it
is and so in response to this and the
fact that he will not give any
information Kingpin basically starts
torturing Frank now of course Frank has
endured all this stuff time and time
again so it's I wouldn't say it's
nothing for him to endure it's nothing
that he can't handle right nothing that
he's incapable of dealing with here and
so in this moment when all of this is
happening the priest alongside the kids
show up with like all these guns
believing that like they can help Frank
Castle of course they have no idea what
they're doing they're immediately
captured they're thrown into the prison
camp with everybody else and like that's
it kudos to them for trying I mean I
don't want to like dismiss them right
like you idiots you know you shouldn't
have tried in the first place no kudos
to them right for Having the courage to
try to pull it off but they were subdued
incredibly fast because they're not
trained Killers now of course the next
thing that the king of death does is he
in fact threatens to kill Mary Jane but
she even tells Frank do not tell him the
location I would rather that my mate
lives on and the survivors survive than
anything right I'll take myself out and
that'll be it right like I will
sacrifice my life for the man that I
love and so while Deadpool is one of
those people who's being kept in a
prison and being monitored by The Red
Skull because the red skull's kind of an
idiot and this reality right now that
he's infected he's not as intelligent as
he normally is Deadpool is able to kind
of goad him and then attack him take his
key free himself grab all his guns and
then go to the aid of Frank Castle but
he overcomes these guys quite readily
freeze Frank Castle and then in turn
Mary Jane Watson actually sees what
Frank Castle is about from her
perspective Frank was here to rescue her
and basically help the survivors live
under the control of Spider-Man right he
would free them all because it was
genuinely the right thing to do this guy
draws his guns and kills everyone
indiscriminately right I mean the
survivors of course survived but all the
infected anybody who's begging anybody
who's asking for Aid anybody who's
saying wait wait wait you know I
Surrender I Surrender No Quarters given
they are all eradicated with swift
Vengeance right I mean it was it's
Judgment Day here guys like I mean this
is the hand of God but I just sweeping
over this Camp that's what Frank Castle
is man this guy is the wrath of God in
human form and in fact even when the
king of death is basically injured and
is literally just kind of there and I
wouldn't go as far as to say begging
Frank Castle but saying like I know you
right I know what you want you want me
to beg Frank won't even let him finish
the sentence he just executes him on the
spot and like that's it from there he
grabs Mary Jane Watson along with the
priests and the survivors and then takes
them back to Spider-Man's camp with Mary
Jane Watson being rescued and Spider-Man
of course being able to reunite with his
mate now the crazy thing about this is
in turn he has this inner monologue
right which is very reminiscent of
Punisher born right for those of you
guys who remember that story where he
basically sold his soul to the devil in
the Vietnam War and eradicated just a
massive number of people he says the
happy reunion a real Hallmark moment and
Spider-Man chimes in and says you keep
bargain bring back my mate my family and
then in turn Mary Jane says I'm sorry
about what I said back there you are a
good man you saved us all the response
of Frank is to pull his gun and he
executes Spider-Man on the spot right
just kills him right there and like
that's it and then when the question of
the of the priest is like for the love
of God why would you do that three
sponsor Frank is because I don't make
deals with monsters he's a bad guy he
killed people he wiped out most of the
Marvel universe that guy needed to die
and that's just the way that it is the
survivors are good guys the monsters are
bad guys and there is no there is
nothing in between that's it it's just
this extreme perception and so following
that Frank Castle basically puts the
survivors on boats where they end up
swimming over to Brooklyn I believe one
of the other five boroughs and then in
turn his response is like this place is
not a place for survivors it's not a
place for the innocent right this is a
place of monsters this is a land of
wolves and there are nothing but wolves
here but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace